[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's master here
check one two
[Music]
patient
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning good morning if I could
have people start gathering to their
seats so we can begin this morning's
breakfast that would be great thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Martin just like Moses is saying Pharaoh
said my people free long is it going to
take before you're able to see that if
one of my brothers or one of my sisters
is deprived of liberty it's none of us
oh no none of us is ever really truly
free
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning everyone
good morning my name is Shayna Smith and
I am currently a senior in civil
engineering here at MIT and have the
pleasure of being your mistress of
ceremonies for this morning's breakfast
so I would like to officially welcome
you to the 25th annual dr. Martin link
link excuse me dr. Martin Luther King
jr. breakfast celebration I'd first like
to take an opportunity to thank
president Charles vest and his wife mrs.
Rebecca vest for hosting this event I
would also like to thank the Honorable
questi Mfume president and CEO of the
National Association for the Advancement
of Colored People for being here today
with us ah so we really appreciate
having you furthermore I would like to
thank the members of the Martin Luther
King jr. committee to whom we can thank
for this breakfast and this event when I
call your names can you please stand and
be recognized
professor Jerome Friedman professor
Kenneth Hale professor Wesley Harris
professor richard Milner assistant
professor of Melissa Nobles
[Applause]
assistant professor Larry Anderson
associate dean Arnold Henderson junior
assistant dean and Davis Shaw
[Applause]
Ronald critchlow the Reverend Jane Gould
Yvette Lane
Trudy Morris
[Applause]
Paul Parra bono
robert's sales
toby whiner
associate provost Phillip clay
ex-officio special assistant to the
president dr. Clarence G Williams
ex-officio jennifer o Martinez
Laurie Smith Britton
and finally we'd also like to thank the
co-chairs Dean Leo Osgood jr. and
professor Michael Feld
[Applause]
thank you all in addition we'd also like
to express our appreciation to the many
student volunteers who were here very
early this morning to help with the
preparations for this event thank you
for your time we would begin the program
with the invocation by Rabbi Joshua Eli
pull out following the invocation the
MLT gospel choir will sing us a song I
believe
and finally breakfast will begin after
breakfast we will have two students
Maribel Gomez class of 2002 and Randall
Pinkett a graduate student guide us in a
reflection on the life and legacy of dr.
King then we will hear some remarks from
dr. Charles best and he will have the
distinct pleasure of introducing our
keynote speaker the Honorable Christian
fumet president and CEO of the n-double
a-c-p
Chancellor Lawrence s Baca will present
the 1998-1999
Martin Luther King Leadership Awards and
following that presentation Provost
Robert a brown will recognize our dr.
Martin Luther King jr. visiting
professors for the 1998-99 academic year
so as the conclusion to the program the
MIT gospel choir will again perform and
lead us as we also join in singing lift
every voice and sing by James Weldon
Johnson now let us begin our program
with the invocation by Rabbi Joshua Elie
plout and right after rabbi plow the
invocation we can begin breakfast
coming together this morning to warm
each other's souls to inspire one
another to continue the struggle for
equality let us listen to and let us act
upon the commandments found in the Bible
and the book of Exodus God calls upon
each one of us to teach our sons and
daughters to teach them the story of the
exodus from Egypt the liberation from
the house of bondage this duty of
teaching our children diligently is
repeated in the book of Deuteronomy
there we are commanded to love God with
all of our mind with all of our strength
and with all of our being to set these
sacred words which are commanded upon
our hearts to teach them faithfully to
our children to speak of them in our
home and on our way when we lie down and
when we rise up and we should bind them
as a sign upon our hand and let them be
a symbol before our eyes and scribing
them on the doorpost of our house and on
our gates scripture commands us the
teaching and learning the vehicles of
education are not a privilege but a duty
learning and teaching our active states
of being
day and night let us labor to bring the
fruits of education to every person to
erase the inequalities and educational
opportunity which so afflict our society
and let us search for and then reach out
to help those who are at a disadvantage
to empower them with all of the
knowledge and wisdom the skills and
learning experiences that will be the
key that opens the door to a better and
more just life on this morning we gather
to honor the spirit of Martin Luther
King jr. a blessed memory to carry on
and transmit the legacy he is bequeath
as we now carry his torch in this
generation let us keep in mind that
every generation that inherits the
victories of the past will not enjoy
them unless it strives to understand
appreciate and cherish them as though
they themselves have fought for them
each generation must exceed 'm anew each
must ever earn its claim to liberty let
us therefore each ask of ourselves how
we intend as individuals to bring equal
educational and work opportunity to
those in need how we intend in our own
way to carry the torch of yesteryear
looking back in time I think of my late
father Walter plowed a rabbi who was a
freedom rider in 1962 fighting the
battle to desegregate public facilities
in Georgia and Florida his heartfelt
responsibility is now mine and I like
the rest of us in this room have a
responsibility to face the unique
challenges of inequality in our own
generation continuing the work of those
who came before us as we sit and break
bread that together and listen and
discuss on this great morning of
celebration of the life and the spirit
of Martin Luther King jr. let us be
grateful for this wonderful opportunity
of a community coming together striving
to forever renew a shared vision let us
remember that after all we are here at
this great Institute of research
learning and teaching because we accept
our mission to be proactive and
fulfilling the dream of providing
teaching and learning experiences for
every American in need
while a good meal now a waiter saw there
is much more to anticipate a 2,000 year
old Jewish saying from the Talmud
reminds us that the person who teaches
his or her neighbor's child will deserve
to sit in the heavenly Academy so maybe
our will in our way
amen
ain't gonna let nobody thorny gonna let
nobody lordy
keep walking keep on talking walking up
to feed on me on a Ledge aggregation
party on alleged aggregation or d-4d
[Applause]
racism
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
on a level Geordi
keep walking keep on talking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're ready to continue on with this
morning's program welcome back I hope
you all have enjoyed your breakfast as
much as I have we can now go on have the
distinct pleasure of introducing two of
our very own students
Maribel Gomez a freshman in chemical
engineering and Randall Pinkett a
graduate student in media arts and
scientists each will share and guide us
through some thoughts and reflections on
the life and legacy of dr. King so I'd
like to introduce Maribel Gomez good
morning everyone my name is Maribel
Gomez and I'm a member of the class of
2002 and I'm currently pursuing a degree
in chemical engineering in the 25 years
since his death dr. Martin Luther King
jr. has become an American Hero
as we remember the life and dream of dr.
King remember the in justices that dr.
King fought for his fight for freedom
equality and dignity for all races and
people his many speeches that awaken
people to the horrors of racial
discrimination and his work that's
banned and touched all minorities and
motivated them to action we remember but
we must also act on his dream to do this
we must follow dr. King's example and
educate ourselves educate ourselves on
the meaning and message of such a great
educator and those whom inspired him
Martin Luther King's ideas his call for
racial equality his faith in the
ultimate triumph of justice his
insistence on the power of non-violence
to bring a major transformation on a
mayor
society are as vital and timely as ever
his life and teachings have had a
profound influence not only on Americans
but of people of all nations dr. King
said nothing in this world is more
dangerous than sincere ignorant and
conscientious stupidity nothing in this
world is more dangerous than sincere
ignorance and conscientious stupidity we
are such a diverse multicultural nation
that we can no longer tolerate injustice
is based on the color of our skin we
must empower ourselves with our
knowledge and become educators ourselves
to those who are ignorant history is
still unfolding our actions today will
be the history of tomorrow we must act
accordingly we must respond to the words
he preached I quote we are faced with
the fact that tomorrow is today we are
confronted with the fierce urgency of
now in this unfolding conundrum of life
in history there is such a thing as
being too late let us not be too late
let us not be too late let us all live
and act by the words of dr. King
let us educate those around us of the
joys of living together in harmony and
let him continue to inspire us to
perform extraordinary acts of courage
and perseverance just like he did when
he ignited one of the most influential
civil rights and economic movements of
the 20th century I'd like to leave you
with dr. King's quote again as a
reminder nothing in this world is more
dangerous than sincere ignorance and
conscientious stupidity
thank you
thank you very very very much Maddy well
for those inspiring and
thought-provoking remarks we will now
proceed with mr. Randal Pinkett Randall
[Music]
Thank You Shana good morning somewhere I
once heard that the great figures among
us have been ordinary people that have
done extraordinary things the Reverend
dr. Martin Luther King jr. did
extraordinary things but at the same
time and I don't think I diminished dr.
King's great legacy by saying this he
was an ordinary man
an ordinary man that did ordinary things
until December 1st 1955 when Rosa Parks
refused to give up her seat on a bus in
Montgomery Alabama and dr. King at the
age of 26 and just barely out of
graduate school was placed at a
crossroad along the path that
constitutes human history it was then
that this man this ordinary man became a
great figure and did extraordinary
things
Robert Frost wrote two roads diverged in
a wood and I I took the one less
traveled by and that has made all the
difference
but in recognition of dr. King's legacy
I posed the following question what
about when there is no Road hmm what
about when there is no road no path to
follow of the many things I've learned
from dr. King's life hi among them is
the notion that each of us in our own
unique way is embarking on a new path
with each passing moment venturing into
uncharted territory and while there are
points and places and moments and times
where our paths cross and intersect and
intertwine no two paths are alike
the Honorable mr. Mfume has walked along
a path his own path our honorees today
mr. Williamson miss Olguin and Professor
Slocum have walked along their own paths
and the Reverend dr. Martin Luther King
jr. walked along his path
so I asked the question once again
ladies and gentlemen what about when
there is no road the answer the road is
made as one walks the road is made as
one box honoring the life and legacy of
dr. King means remembering that just as
he walked along his path and was able to
do great things we must walk along our
path knowing that we too can do great
things because we put dr. King too high
on a pedestal if we allow his
accomplishments to in some way become
unachievable or unattainable then not
only do we do with this service to his
life and his legacy but we diminish our
own capacity as ordinary people to do
extraordinary things god bless you and
God bless you dr. King
[Applause]
once again I'd like to thank both
Maribel and Randall for sharing their
thoughts and remarks on dr. King I hope
that everyone here has had a chance to
really take in what was said and reflect
for themselves I would like to now
introduce the 15th president of MIT dr.
Charles M vest who will give some
remarks and then introduce our keynote
speaker the Honorable Christian fumet
president vest
Thank You Shana mr. Mfume at least you
get me between those kids and yourself
before I begin my remarks I want to take
a moment to recognize several
distinguished representatives of the
larger Cambridge community who have
joined with us for today's program from
the Cambridge City Council I am very
pleased to welcome our current mayor
Frank do they
and also his predecessor city councilor
ken Reeves we also are very pleased to
have with us we also are very pleased to
have with us city councilor Kathryn tree
and a fellow
the Cambridge police commissioner Ronnie
Watson the mayor's school liaison and
Lee foster the mayor's chief of staff
Lisa Jana caucus and the coordinator of
the mayor's initiative on race and class
we shall Farnum welcome to all of you
we're also delighted to welcome to this
morning's events a delegation of leaders
from the Cambridge Public School System
which is establishing its own dialogue
on race relations under the guidance of
school committee member Denise
Simmons miss Simmons is with us today
and accompanying her fellow school
committee member Robyn Harris
Superintendent of Schools Bobby Dell
Sandro and deputy separate area deputy
superintendent Patrick Murphy welcome to
all of you I think it's fair to say that
MIT and the city of Cambridge are on a
shared journey and the ways in which we
work together in education development
and civic affairs is something that
gives me great confidence in our future
it's good to have all of you here this
morning just four years ago the keynote
speaker for this event was judge a Leon
Higginbotham jr. this past year after a
half century of service as one of our
nation's foremost jurists scholars and
advocates for civil rights judge
Higginbotham was taken from us I could
not let this occasion pass without
saying a few words about this truly
extraordinary man Leon Higginbotham was
a hero for many Americans here at MIT we
will forever be grateful for his
compelling and effective advocacy on our
behalf during what became known as the
overlap case as many in this room
remember in 1991 the United States
Justice Department brought an antitrust
suit against MIT and against the Ivy
League universities alleging collusion
in the way in which we award financial
aid to our students we argued that our
practices sought to ensure that students
would be awarded
relate solely on the basis of their
financial need and that different
schools would not get into financial
bidding wars for students judge
Higgenbotham who had recently retired
from the bench believed our case was so
compelling that he volunteered to
present pro bono the amici briefs on our
behalf at the appellate court a staunch
and effective supporter of affirmative
action and diversity Leon Higginbotham
argued that the principles at stake in
the overlap case had to do with both
public policy and ethical norms and one
of those norms he said and I'm quoting
is that those people who are poor but
who are talented should have the same
opportunity to have an entry into these
great universities as did the Kennedys
and the Rockefellers and the Cabot's and
the lodges one of the reasons he worked
so hard to preserve the practice of
need-blind admission and need-based
financial aid was his recognition that
this policy was a blessing not only for
those who received the opportunity but
for the larger society as well after he
had made his argument to the appellate
court an argument that prevailed judge
Higginbotham got a letter from an
antitrust lawyer who had heard his
presentation to the court that lawyer
observed that in the future quote many
poor white kids will get into Ivy League
schools and they will not recognize that
this option was made possible because of
the arguments of a black lawyer and the
Congressional Black Caucus made on
behalf of MIT for all of the poor kids
of America as Judge Higginbotham
reminded us when he spoke here in 1995
we meet here today to acknowledge that
Martin Luther King's legacy was not
merely to black people or to brown
people his legacy was one that embraced
all people this is perhaps the least
understood and most misrepresented
back to the ongoing debate over policies
designed to promote more equal
opportunity and greater diversity in
American society
Leon Higginbotham knew that society
could not progress unless it progressed
as a whole with no one left behind or
pushed aside today this fundamental
policy this fundamental principle is
again under direct assault across
America the old guy the old cry of your
gain is my loss is heard on college
campuses corporate boardrooms in the
halls of Congress as a matter of
profound and disturbing irony but at a
time of unparalleled prosperity many of
those who have the most the most wealth
the most access the most skills the most
power seemed to be more reluctant than
ever to invest those resources in a
strong and just society in order to
bring that strength and justice to our
society all of us must continue to think
on and speak out about the issue of race
sensitive emissions in American higher
education since 1978 our colleges and
universities have designed and
administered admissions policies under
the guidance of the Bakke decision which
was forged in the Supreme Court by
Thurgood Marshall this guidance is clear
race may be one of several factors
considered when we select students for
admissions to our campuses this simple
statement in my view is the appropriate
one under it as bill Bowen and Derek Bok
have clearly demonstrated in their
recent book the shape of the river our
institutions have contributed
substantially to the establishment of a
strong black middle class and therefore
to the strengthening of America as a
whole but the quest is far from complete
today through referenda such as
proposition 209 in California initiative
measure 200 in state of Washington
public university
are losing their ability to utilize race
enca t'v admissions or even the ability
to mount outreach programs to minority
youngsters in primary and secondary
schools from mi t--'s point of view more
dangerous still are successful attacks
in the courts especially the hopwood
case dealing with admission to the
University of Texas law school a case
involving undergraduate admissions at
the University of Michigan currently
pending in the courts may be the most
important to date now many argue on
behalf of these referenda and court
challenges and do so in good faith that
it is discriminatory to make race a
consideration in admissions and that
students should be admitted only on what
they consider to be merit in my view
there are two quite elementary flaws in
this argument first we have laid upon
the table several factors things such as
grades ranks in class test scores
geographic distribution breadth of
interest unusual accomplishments outside
the classroom race economic status
international mixture and so forth and
so on those who challenge us reach out
and remove from the table one and only
one factor race and say thou shalt not
consider this second their underlying
assumption is that we can accurately
measure specific quality of our
applicants by a simple number or two
they seem to seek a world in which we
are each ranked at age eighteen by some
easy indicator like an SAT score which
thereby determines our breadth of
opportunity we believe that building a
class for a great university by using a
range of factors promotes a better
educational experience for all of our
students and that it increases our
ability to contribute to building the
strong coherent productive society
this nation will need in the next
century the logic underlying this belief
to use a favorite MIT phrase is
intuitively obvious yet far too many of
us still cannot seem to understand the
old patterns of exclusion and separation
did not work and must not be restored
they don't work for society and they
really don't work for individuals to the
contrary individual fulfillment is
enabled and enhanced by participation in
the larger community here on our campus
the recently issued report of the task
force on student life and learning
reminds us that excellence in research
and education arise not only from
individual efforts but also from
commingling of diverse ideas
perspectives the challenge of
competition and of teamwork and the
support of a nurturing community the
message underlying the task force's
recommendation is that MIT must become
more than just the sum of its parts and
in order to educate a new generation of
leaders for an increasingly
interconnected global society we must by
our own example show students how to
function communicate and thrive in a
diverse environment one promising effort
in community building at MIT is
occurring in our facilities department
and on our campus police force we're
working and managing in a diverse
environment has made an explicit part of
each person's career development while
the program is relatively new early
evidence suggests that the direct
attention to training and evaluation and
managing such issues can improve
communication productivity and employee
satisfaction for everyone of course many
of the same pressures and problems that
affect our larger society remain part of
our everyday life at MIT we are still
only at the beginning of a long and
difficult journey
I hope however that even in time
of controversy we hold on to the example
of such leaders as dr. King and judge
Higginbotham who remind us that our
journey cannot be completed alone unless
all of us help and each of us unless all
of us help each to make our own way we
will never realize the highest potential
we have for excellence and achievement
in designing our admissions policies in
shaping our curricula and advising our
students and working together we must
never lose sight of the truth expressed
in these words written by James Taylor
to honor the memory of dr. King we are
bound together by the tasks that lie
before us and the road that lies ahead
we are bound and we are bound thank you
again very much for being here this
morning and for sharing this small part
of a great journey thank you
and now it's my pleasure and honor to
introduce this morning's keynote speaker
the Honorable cuisine fumet president
and CEO of the n-double a-c-p this
annual ceremony commemorating dr. Martin
Luther King jr. has been an important
feature of the MIT calendar for the last
quarter century over that time we have
been graced with many fine speakers each
of whom has made a unique contribution
to the history and the cumulative impact
of this event the experience and
achievements of this year's keynote
speaker however are so impressive and so
relevant that it would be difficult to
conceive of a better or more welcome
choice his own life journey is witnessed
to the transforming influence of
determination education and vision in
the life of an individual and a society
raised in Baltimore's Inner City
he graduated from Morgan State
University and from the Johns Hopkins
School of International Studies he then
began his political career back on home
ground as a Baltimore City Councilman in
1986 he was elected to Congress where he
served for 10 years as representative of
Maryland's seventh district in the
course of his congressional career
mr. and fumet was a powerful advocate
for landmark legislation affecting civil
rights and economic development during
his tenure in Congress he served as
chair of the joint Senate House Economic
Committee and his other committee
assignments included the ethics
committee banking and financial services
committee the Committee on education of
the Small Business Committee in 1996 he
resigned from Congress to assume the
presidency of the n-double a-c-p
where his leadership has had a
significant impact on a wide range of
civil rights issues in addition to his
work with the n-double-a-cp miss
from fumet is active in the world of
higher education he serves on the Morgan
State University Board of Regents the
senior Advisory Committee in the John F
Kennedy School of Government at Harvard
University the Meyerhoff national
advisory board of the University of
Maryland and the Board of Trustees of
the Enterprise Foundation and I believe
from our table conversation also on the
Johns Hopkins board now he's member of
Big Brothers and Big Sisters and he is
the author of a critically acclaimed
autobiography entitled no free ride when
it comes to Equal Opportunity and social
progress for all Americans we could seek
no stronger advocate please join me in
welcoming the Honorable quasi Mfume
thank you very much
allow me if I might to begin my remarks
by thanking dr. best for those kind and
overly gracious set of comments and for
his leadership at this historic
university but probably this morning
more than anything else for being a
buffer between me and the - very
impressive students that spoke before me
I am particularly happy doctor vests
that you invoke the name of Leon
Higginbotham who was a very dear friend
and probably the most important reason
why I left my work in the Congress to
join the NAACP after many conversations
with Judge Higginbotham and after many
opportunities to understand his
reasoning as to why it was important for
me to do that I ultimately did just that
and was here just a couple of months ago
to participate in his homegoing service
and would say to particularly students
who may have not had the opportunity to
meet Leon Higginbotham you find a way to
either get to the library or to get back
on the internet or to get to someone who
did to find out about this extraordinary
individual I'd also like to thank all of
the people who have made this morning's
event possible and there are a lot of
them and I was particularly happy last
night that I got a chance to meet many
of them I'd like if I might
on a point of personal privilege to
really think dr. leo Osgood and
professor Michael felt they have through
perhaps some difficulty but more
importantly through a number of
different circumstances that we probably
are not aware of continue to find a way
to make this possible and to remind all
of us about the need to take time to
commemorate and to remember I want to
also say to Provost Robert Brown and all
the others who have worked very hard on
this event that I do thank you and I
know I speak on behalf of students who
are here and those who are not who
recognize now even if it is in hindsight
how important this remembrance is to
miss Gomez and mr. Pinkett I want to
thank both of you for your energy for
the opportunity to meet you last night
but more importantly for the energy and
the sense of understanding you displayed
a little while ago with respect to why
it is important to remember and I'd also
if I might like to acknowledge as was
the case earlier the presence of the
mayor of Cambridge and many many other
honored guests not the least of which
are several distinguished members of our
organization our state conference
president here in the New England area
miss Charlotte Nelson who is somewhere
out there Charlotte and the presidents
of our Boston and Cambridge chapters
Linney Elkins Jacquie Carol I know a
borough blurter is here and a few others
thank all of you for for coming out and
supporting me and for coming out also to
work with this community as you do day
in and day out could we give all those
persons a round of applause
I bring you greetings this morning on
behalf of the NAACP our 1700 branches in
50 states the District of Columbia
Germany Japan and Korea at the National
Association for the Advancement of
Colored People we believe that colored
people come in all colors for it was the
n-double-a-cp that saw America through
the troubled years of Jim Crow and
second-class citizenship in legal
lynchings through the years of
manufactured grandfather clauses and
poll taxes and literacy tests where you
had to tell how many bubbles were in a
bar of soap just to be allowed to vote
we fought over the years the just fight
to integrate the military and to end
official segregation as we knew it and
we found also a way to help a nation
divided against itself through the
confusion and the turbulence of the
1960s and then later through the I isms
and the in differences of the 1980s and
so it is not for us a matter of having
come a long long way but rather and
instead it is a matter of having still
yet a long long way to go
that in turn begs the question not when
do we get there but what path do we take
and that is where your themes of
teaching and learning and inclusion come
into play you see the light really does
bright burn bright here at and for MIT
you are a place in many respects where
for some people dreams have come true
and given birth to other dreams of
service and academic excellence you have
been entrusted with a mighty vision and
you have proven in many respects to be
worthy stewards some of you have worked
hard to make sure that your talents and
I buried in the ground but rather
invested well in the hearts and in the
minds of
our greatest asset our young people the
late dr. Benjamin Mays of Morehouse
College once said that he or she who
starts behind in the race of life what
either have to run faster or forever
remain behind the young men and women
who have kept this tradition of
remembering alive now for all these 25
years in fact have run faster and so I
applaud them and those brave souls no
matter how small and number they may be
who labor here at this University who
like tillers of the soil continued to
push and to prod and cajole for a
greater University commitment to
diversity and equal opportunity they
know almost intuitively that our ability
as a nation to survive will depend
particularly on how we deal with our
increasingly pluralistic society and so
as a preface to my remarks I would
challenge others today to take the route
that those individuals have taken it is
one of embracing diversity while seeking
to promote reciprocal understandings
recognizing as we do that quite frankly
it's easier to do nothing and so because
we all want to do something let's start
if we might by putting in proper context
the man who we have come to commemorate
this morning the rabbi spoke of the Old
Testament let me go even beyond the book
of Exodus and to talk for just a moment
about the book of Genesis 37th chapter
because it underscores in many respects
the age-old desire by a lot of people to
undercut visionaries by trying to do
away with their dreams it says in the
37th chapter that and when they saw him
from
afar even before he had come near to
them they conspired against him to slay
him and they said one to another behold
the dreamer cometh come now therefore
and let us slay him and we will cast him
into some old pit and we will say that
some evil beast has devoured him and we
shall see what becomes of his dream
Martin Luther King jr. uh nod by opinion
unsubdued by flattery undismayed by
disaster confronted life with the
courage of his convictions and
confronted death with the courage of his
faith unless we ever forget we are
talking about a young man 26 years of
age when his face first appeared on the
cover of Time magazine 35 years of age
when he won the Nobel Peace Prize 39
years of age on the afternoon of his
assassination it is important to
understand that because it's important
to have a full appreciation of his
capacity and his indignation over the
absence of justice a Greek historian at
least legend has it was once asked when
would justice ever come to Athens and
after thinking about the magnitude of
the question he thoughtfully replied
that justice would never come to Athens
until all of those who were not injured
were just as indignant as all of those
who are and so I hope and pray that
those of you in this room
this morning who are Caucasian or white
that you understand the indignity of
those like myself who are not at the
scourge of racism and bigotry and
unequal treatment and that you in your
own way will become just as indignant I
hope and pray that those who are here
today who are of Asian and Indian
Hispanic and Native American ancestry
that you understand as we must the real
need never to give up on the idea of
coalition building even when some in
your number and some in mine
prefer to go the other way and to talk
only about our individual agendas or the
power of our individual groups and I
hope and pray that those of you who sit
here today who are African American or
of African ancestry that you understand
as we must the real need at some point
in time to get beyond blame to get
beyond excuses and to start once again
doing for ourselves
if we were to leave here and to go over
to the lab and sit before any computer
and to request from ourselves a simple
computer printout of all the salient
issues facing us as a nation it is clear
that the list of problems to be printed
out by that computer would in fact be
overwhelming institutionally government
military church and school are all under
attack for either real or imagined
defects politically the Joint Center for
Political Studies in Washington would
remind us that 35 years after passage of
the Voting Rights Act and 30 years after
outright efforts to register and to
elect people that still in this country
less than 7% of all the elected
officials are of African or Hispanic or
Asian ancestry socially that same
printout would suggest that the issue of
race and skin color still dominate too
many aspects of American life both at
home and abroad economically it would
suggest to us in the clearest of terms
that after four years of congressional
acquiescence to the concept of Robin
Hood in Reverse the haves now have more
and the have-nots have not at all the
gap continues to widen
and educationally it would point out the
obvious that too many of our public
schools are overcrowded and ill-equipped
and drugs tend to be more available than
textbooks and that too many young people
in those schools because they are a lot
there are being promoted because of
their age or because of this size only
to be rewarded at the end of 12 years
with the equivalent document that would
suggest it was a certificate of
attendance but not a meaningful high
school diploma and yet we know that the
student in those schools not different
from students in other schools have one
thing that defines them and that is that
the student who makes the grade is still
the one who comes early and stays late
to learn the meaning of the lesson but
never to lessen the meaning of the
assignment and that the teacher in those
schools who makes the grade it's still
the teacher who teaches the touch of
life and not just to make a living just
a few months from now we will witness
what many in the press will refer to as
a celebration of the 45th anniversary of
the Supreme Court decision Brown versus
the Board of Topeka Kansas when on May
17 1954 nine men robed in black
assembled on that historic day to
announce their unanimous verdict there
was in fact dancing in the streets at
black colleges classes were suspended
that day and parties were hastily
assembled and there was dancing in the
streets of Richmond and Raleigh and
Baltimore in Washington and people began
to believe in their hearts and in the
innermost parts of their being that our
nation was at long last launched
and unalterable course with a firm
determination that in terms of public
education
we were now prepared to overcome the
legacies of the past but in 1969 just a
decade or so later a high-ranking
official in the White House who is now a
United States Senator advised the
president then and what later became
known as the celebrated memorandum on
public education when he said mr.
president we have made so much progress
moving black people into the mainstream
of American economic educational and
social life that our nation's policies
from this point on with respect to the
status of those people ought be accorded
benign neglect that neglect once
proposed as benign in too many respects
today for too many people is a neglect
that is malignant and so when we think
about dr. King in his capacity remember
also what Randall said this was an
ordinary man who was called on to do
extraordinary things and I underscore
that because God still calls on ordinary
people all of us as Booker T Washington
once said to cast our buckets down where
we are to pick our own battlefield and
to make a difference in a real and
meaningful way when dr. vest talked
about these attacks on the ability of
young people to matriculate as a result
of efforts to deny opportunity that's
all tied in to the exact same thing we
know that affirmative action has met
with resistance from its inception and
that lastly for the last five years or
so there has been a sustained attack
nationwide a movement throughout the
country
to gut and to destroy affirmative action
as we know it and in the process destroy
diversity programs as well programs both
in the workplace and on college campuses
prop 209 initiative 200 the University
of Michigan case which is now pending
the Hopwood decision in the aggregate
they chip away at the ability of people
who come behind you or at least want to
come behind you students to sit where
you sit now interestingly enough the
rationale for this attack has been
unsubstantiated reports of widespread
color blindness people just say well you
know things are different and we're a
colorblind society and so we don't need
to help you with a Hispanic surname we
don't need to help you because you
happen to be of African ancestry we
don't really need to help you either
because you come from the Pacific Rim we
don't have to help you who grew up in
Appalachia we don't have to do anything
for anybody because color blindness has
broken out throughout this society oh if
that were the case this program would be
more than a celebration it would be a
magnificent celebration and so I say to
you and remind myself as we think about
why we have come together what it means
to remember dr. King and what our own
personal challenges that it is not so
much
the hypocrisy zuv the pass the things
that we know about that we find
repulsive the institution of slavery the
attacks on individuals because of their
religious beliefs the attacks on
individuals because of their surnames or
because of their sexual preferences it
is not so much the hypocrisy of the past
as much as it is for those people of
color the hypocrisy of the present
that's what should concern us item
number one in 1990 the Urban Institute
bipartisan funding bipartisan
participation conducted a nationwide
study over a number of years and
concluded unequivocally that there was
unequal treatment of minority job
seekers item number two in 1991 the
holiday health spa Club chain was found
to have systematically discriminated
against women of color item number three
in 1993 Denny's restaurant settle claims
of discrimination because they refused
to serve black customers who happen to
be six gentlemen guarding the president
is Secret Service agents prepared to
take a bullet that day to preserve
democracy item number four 1994 the
Chevy Chase Bank agrees to an eleven
million dollar settlement because they
redlined
communities and and neighborhoods or at
least were accused of doing it and
refused to go in the court to defend
themselves as many other institutions
had previously done
item five 1995 the glass ceiling
Commission concludes that women
Hispanics and african-americans are
still disproportionately represented
among the nation's working poor item 6
1996 Texaco the infamous tape where
executives are caught and loosely making
fun of Jewish holidays and black
holidays in referring to people as jelly
beings of color and talking very very
openly about why it's important not to
let those people have an opportunity and
lastly 1998 data released under the Home
Mortgage Disclosure Act showed
nationwide that black and Latino
borrowers were turned down at
increasingly higher rates when applying
for mortgage loans more than 50% of all
those who applied were denied loans at
banks across this nation and so
regrettably discrimination is not an
article of the pass it is instead an
article of the present and so what then
really becomes our role in dealing with
what we are faced with we find ourselves
living at a time when our sense of
community can no longer be taken for
granted that's for sure we find
ourselves at a time where information
technology has made it possible for us
to communicate across oceans across
continents across every conceivable
boundary of race and culture and to do
that almost instantaneously but our
technology has almost also made it
possible for us to be able to live and
work in complete isolation from our
neighbors and fellow citizens things
have changed
be nice to be like these birds just fly
around all day long you know have a
little bite deed on that table and fly
up to the balcony and but things have
changed the common experiences that have
made us recognize each other as members
of a community of Americans are becoming
less common each year scab labor
unbridled poverty second-class
citizenship and violent crime chip away
at that sense of community every day
hate speech hate groups hate radio and
hate crimes are attempting to divide
those same communities like never before
and yet we know if we lose that sense of
community that same community that
Martin King spoke about from an old
Birmingham jail we lose much of what has
made America distinctive among the
nations of the world as foreign visitors
have observed since the beginning of
this Republic America's greatest
strength has been her identity as a
group and a collection of different
people whose common destiny was more
powerful than their diverse backgrounds
or stations in life and that is why
people in this country under the
umbrella of the NAACP and hundreds of
other groups have always made an attempt
to try to communicate across lines of
race class age and religion it's not
because they were foolish or foolhardy
it's because they understood the fact
that it is harder to accept that the
road less traveled is the road less
certain but it is the proper road for us
to be on anyway it is that path that
Randle talked about that we beat out of
the wilderness that makes a difference
the really really understanding of what
it means to be on a road less traveled
that we
are not streetlights and and paved
sidewalks where there is at each turn
some degree of uncertainty but certainly
at the end of the road if we are
persistent a great deal of satisfaction
that opposite path the one that's paved
and well lit the one that we think has
no curves that's a path of cynicism
contempt distrust and suspicion it is
best exposed by the Timothy McVeigh's of
this world and that road to be sure
leads to separatism suspicion division
and destruction and so collectively and
individually our charge has been renewed
regrettably by an old plague that has
come back to America a plague that has
resurfaced with great abandon a national
scourge if you will of insensitivity and
intolerance whether it is the repugnant
act of burning black churches or
desecrating synagogues whether it is
increase violence from militia groups or
bombings of federal buildings or
demonstrations against immigrants simply
because they cannot speak as we do
tolerance for too many as once again
become a dirty word you look at what
happened out there and Laramie Wyoming
the student matriculating and because
someone thought they should determine
what his sexual preference ought to be
decided that they and not God had the
right to take his life it would happen
in June in Jasper Texas 300 miles from
nowhere James Byrd Jr on a street corner
trying to get home and gets grabbed and
drugged by a truck for three miles until
his arms and neck and and limbs are
dismembered because he just happened
to be black no dr. king were here he
remind us the Jim Crow senior is dead
but Jim Crow jr. is alive and well
and so the great moral challenge for all
of us is to separate the truth from the
trick and the challenge rests on our
shoulders because in an era of smaller
vision rampant apathy and celebrated
mediocrity we so desperately need those
men and women will stand up and speak
out for that which is right and to fight
back against that which is wrong to
really mean it when we say that racism
sexism and anti-semitism are wrong to
know as a matter of critical fact that
black bigotry is just as cruel and evil
as white bigotry to understand
intuitively that that xenophobia and
homophobia an immigrant bashing and
union bashing and city bashing deplete
us as a nation they robbed us of some
lofty place in history and relegate us
back to where we have been and
regrettably in many respects are still
now and so and speaking out as dr. King
would speak out we must be honest and
true to our own sense of fairness for
the great enemy of the truth is very
often not the lie that's deliberate its
contrived it's dishonest the great enemy
of the truth very often is the myth
because that is persistent and
persuasive and unrealistic too often we
hold fast to the conclusions of other
people we subject all facts to a kind of
prefabricated set of interpretations as
my grandmother said we we enjoy the
comfort of opinion without the
discomfort of thought and yet we have
spent 5,000 years as a race of human
beings trying to drag ourselves out of
the primeval slime by searching for
truths and moral absolutes
and yet in its purest form truth is not
a polite tap on the shoulder that is as
Martin King reminded us a Holling
reproach and what Moses brought down
from Mount Sinai 2,000 years ago was not
the ten suggestions but rather a
blueprint for life
Mirabel Gomez said it earlier and I
think it bears repeating as we talk and
remember and reflect on the life of dr.
King those words that said that we we
are confronted with the fierce urgency
of now and that in this unfolding
conundrum of life in history there
really is such a thing as being too late
for procrastination is still the great
thief of time and so consequently
students the degree that you will one
day receive from MIT will in fact
represent many things it will be a
reward for your academic excellence it
will be a reminder of a debt that you
can never repay your parents it will be
both a source of relief and respect to
your professors but more than anything
it will be a license to learn and so age
has given me the arrogance and
experience has given me the urgency to
tell you what life looks like from my
side of the river my generation was the
first to think that we might not have
any time at all and your generation is
the first to be born knowing it so there
will be those beyond these doors and
beyond this activity today who will
counsel you to be silent in this
reactionary time they will suggest
students that you look the other way and
hope for the best but I refuse to stand
mute when opportunity is denied and
justice is deferred and I challenge you
not to stand mute also and so when the
timid come running to you to say that
they fear even to try anymore
we must reply as Martin King did from an
old Birmingham jail that now is the time
when you are told to wait for tomorrow
or the next tomorrow for the next
election or the next generation
we must reply that now is the time I
believe and I um believe submit to you
this morning that we must use this
occasion this glittering reminder of the
success of our experience to recommit
ourselves to sharing a basic dream it is
the dream of Martin Luther King and
fannie lou hamer the dream of Du Bois
and Washington and Tubman and Douglass
the dream of all those nameless and
faceless people who made their bodies
bridges over generations that you might
run across and one day get to the
University we must do that not just
through our prose our poetry or our
prayers but also through our actions
action which removes a large part of our
distress by changing the conditions
around us that created it and so as I go
to my seat let me say to you and again
remind myself that I have not given up
on the American idea or the American
possibility and I like dr. King would
urge you not to give up also I am
convinced that this nation still stands
before the world as perhaps the last
expression of a possibility of mankind
devising a social order where justices
the supreme ruler and law is but its
instrument where freedom is the dominant
creed and order but its principle where
equity is the common practice and
fraternity the true human condition and
to take that belief and to run with it
beyond this university beyond your years
of youth and beyond all else and to make
a real difference in this nation and in
your generation and I challenge you as
dr. King would to do that right now
and when they saw him from afar even
before he had come near to them they
conspired against him to slay him and
they said one to another behold the
dreamer cometh come now therefore and
let us slay him we will cast him into
some o pit and say that some evil beast
has devoured him and we shall see what
becomes of his dream thank you thank you
again
the Honorable questing and fumet for his
inspiring words
we really appreciate listening to them
and I know as a student I can take a lot
of that back and use it in my future
life so thank you again
I now have the honor of introducing
Chancellor Lawrence s ba cow who will
present the 1999 MLK Leadership Awards
Chancellor back out thank you thank you
very much Shana first I would like to
thank the committee for the privilege
and honor of being able to to be here
today to present these awards this is a
day in which we not only remember dr.
King remember his teachings remember his
legacy but we also honor him by
recognizing those members of our
community who through their actions and
their deeds have really embraced and
personified his ideals who have in
Randall's words found their own way
their paths have created their own road
in doing so we recognize a member of our
faculty we recognize one of our alumni
and we recognize one of our students
among us in many ways I think this is a
fitting tribute that we look across MIT
to the various generations that are
represented within our community before
I would like to call up our honorees
today however I have to say something
not as Chancellor but rather as a member
of our faculty and I really direct my
comments largely in response to I think
the remarkable words of Randall the
remarkable words of Marybel those of us
who have the privilege of teaching here
at MIT really bear an extraordinary
responsibilities because we are
entrusted with absolutely extraordinary
students and you see today before you
not only in our student speakers but
also in our students and our alumni who
we are about to to honor the great
privilege that we have and indeed the
great burden and responsibility that we
that we take among ourselves to
try and lead to guide and to inspire
there are times in which I think that as
faculty at MIT we should be required to
take the Hippocratic oath first do no
harm we really have such remarkable
students and they constantly remind us
what a truly remarkable place this is
Randall Mirabel thank you again for your
inspiring words our first honoree today
is a member of our faculty
Alex Slocum Alex would you please come
up here
alex is a remarkable person in many
different dimensions he happens to be
one of our most gifted teachers at MIT
he happens to be one of our most and I
mean this warmly Alex unusual
personalities and distinctive
personalities at MIT and I think Alex
embraces the very best of what we hope
an MIT faculty member would be a scholar
of the first rank an inspiring teacher
and somebody who also pays extraordinary
attention to his students I would like
to read to you from the letter from dr.
vest that recognizes Alex for his
accomplishments in his letter of doctor
of nomination
professor NAMM sue this is Alex
Department said to Partin head and
mechanical engineering cited your
innovative and intellectually
captivating efforts with MIT minority
students and particularly you work on
activities sponsored by the urban design
corps in the engineering design workshop
of the second summer program creating
and developing products under your
supervision has been an invaluable
experience for many young people from
diverse backgrounds as an enthusiastic
teacher and caring mentor you have
helped these aspiring engineers and
designers to acquire the knowledge and
skills that lead not only to greater
self-confidence but also to academic and
professional success these generous and
lasting contributions to the lives of
your students embody the essence of dr.
King's philosophy and vision Alex it's
my privilege to recognize you today as
one of the the winners of the Martin
Luther King achievement award
congratulations
thanks Larry I appreciate it
I wrote a little poem inspired by mr. M
fumet because I usually do things kind
of at the moment take what I have and
try to build a road with it so when they
try this to win a battle the pen is
mightier than the sword to build a road
we will find that the bite is mightier
than the bulldozer two extraordinary
students started me on my road mark
Graham who's over here somewhere art
stand up a minute please
and Marty Culpepper who I think mr. and
fumet met at dinner last night I was
just your average ordinary geek patting
away having fun and these two young
people made me realize that there's a
big wilderness and if we build this road
everybody can be a lot happier so we
have partnered to create what we call
the urban design core just like the
Peace Corps strove to provide basic
needs and to set things for people who
didn't have food or clothing and shelter
we hope to build on the Internet we call
the urban design core a place where we
will teach people to create where they
can take their creations and post them
where businesses can then take those
creations and employ people and create
jobs
we're going to harness the power of
creativity we believe throughout the
world to help all people lift themselves
up that is our dream and that dream is
kind of inspired by dr. King so we have
a little poem that we wrote for him too
and that I'll finish with that because
I'm only allowed I think 47 more seconds
his dream was dedicated to our parents
they gave us life they shielded us from
strife there why we must carry on his
dream was dedicated to our everlasting
Souls this is why we will work into the
night this is why we will work for what
is right this is what bring us into
God's fold his dream was dedicated to
our children they renew the life within
us they drive our problems from us
they're why we must stay on the right
path his dream was dedicated to the
Almighty who gave us ambition and drive
who gave us the ability to create not
stagnate who we will not let down thank
you
and can I give this thing eat okay mr.
boomy could you could you come back up
please pretty please
but what I would like to do is present
you with what we think will be our
kickoff CD for the urban design core
it's called the journey of the lost
souls and it was written by Mark Graham
and we actually have a tape - and then
another fun student privilege of knowing
a toe is are you around anywhere he
created this fantastic poster and we've
inscribed on it the journey the lost
souls poem and I think it very clearly
shows what we are path we want to create
and I think H of the big version of it
you have out on displaying Lobby seven
right oh but we'll find it
[Applause]
thank you Alex for being Alex our next
honoree
is Richard Williamson Richard would you
please come up Richard is an alumnus MIT
class of 1987 Richard 85 I had my
instructions were wrong 1985 Richard has
chosen a relatively unusual path for an
MIT alumnus and that is that most the
world tends to think of us and I'm an
alumnus as well so I can say us as as
engineers as scientists as geeks Richard
however has made his way in the world in
a different way he is a teacher in the
Boston Public Schools and not just any
kind of a teacher
Richard teaches at an alternative school
the school of his choosing a school
which is for young men and women who
have been expelled from the Boston
Public Schools Richard has chosen a path
where he can really have an influence on
the lives of people who are in many
cases most in need of inspiration of
leadership of support and he has done so
in a way that has touched the lives of
many of Boston's youth in addition to
his activities as as a teacher in the
Boston Public Schools I have to pull out
Richards card which I think is wonderful
Richard has also formed another
organization to help Boston's youth
which has the absolutely wonderful and
inspiring name of God's Posse
Incorporated
I read to you from the letter of award
from dr. vest to Richard in his letter
of nomination dr. Raymond II Samuel of
Brigham and Women's Hospital cited your
unwavering commitment and selfless
service to young people in the
neighborhoods of Roxbury and Dorchester
your efforts as a teacher mentor and
community leader have brought hope and
inspiration to the lives of promising
young people who otherwise may have been
lost neglected or forgotten your
outstanding work and strong
contributions are a fitting tribute to
the legacy of dr. King and to all who
are Pat who passionately believe in the
great tradition of education and service
Richard in giving you this Ward award
today I want you to know that through
you work your work you honor all of MIT
its alumni and all the people that serve
our great community congratulations
[Applause]
I'm reminded of the preacher that said
when Jesus was coming into the town of
Jerusalem and the crowds were cheering
and worshiping him that the donkey
realized that the praise was for the
Lord and not for him and I feel like
that donkey Scriptures teach to whom
much is given much is required and I
felt that I've been one who's been
blessed and given much and so I felt
that my obligation to seek a way to give
back not knowing how not knowing that
path to take but I had the opportunity
to come to MIT and to be taught by this
illustrious faculty and to learn some
things that challenged me and taught me
that anything is possible if you work
hard at it and God opened up doors for
me to be able to leave here and go into
the Roxbury community and work with
young men particularly young men who are
considered the throwaways the castaways
the super-predators those whom the
prisons are being built for those homes
institutions are not looking forward to
them coming and to see in them the
potential for our country to see in them
a leadership to seeing them gifts and
talents and abilities to see them them
it's a gift of God and God has privilege
to be with the ability to be able to
reach them teach them and to lead them
and I thank God for that opportunity and
that privilege I'd like to acknowledge
this morning also my co-founder mr.
Chris Womack who I work with in God's
path if you stand up please
and two young men that I work with mr.
Stephen McGuire McGuire who's a member
of God's Posse and mr. Daniel Davis with
the senior at community academy in
Roxbury where I work
finally I'd just like to say dr. King
said a man is not worthy to live until
he's found something worth dying for and
I found in these young men young men in
the streets of Boston something worth
dying for
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Richard
our third honoree adriana hogan adriana
witch please come up now I have to tell
something which most people in this room
just know from having been around this
place but for our visitors I have to
share with you the fact that MIT
students probably work harder and longer
than any other people in any other job
on the face of the planet in fact we
have an expression at MIT that if you
can't get your work done in 24 hours in
a day start working nights so it's all
the more remarkable when one encounters
a student like Adriana who in spite of
bearing the burden of an extraordinarily
challenging curriculum instant in spite
of of having accomplished academically
in an extraordinarily high level still
manages to find time amidst all of her
other activities to serve her community
and to do so with grace and with honor
and with dignity and to find time for
others who are less fortunate and to
find time to pass on the tradition and
inspired others so that they may
accomplish someday as she has done as
well I read to you from Adriana's letter
of award in her letter of nomination
Dean and Davis Shaw advisor to the
National Society of Hispanic
Professional Engineers cited the depth
of your commitment to helping fellow
students in the MIT community your
outstanding work as a leader has
motivated many peers and you have
contributed effectively to a range of
student organizations as the calculus
teacher's assistants assistant with the
minority introduction to engineering and
science program mites you inspired 30
talented secondary school students to
strive for higher academic goals
equally admirable is your ability to be
fully engaged in your own scholarship
while never losing sight of the
needs of others the Martin Luther King
jr. committee believes that you
represent much of what dr. King wanted
for all youth in this society your
dedication to his vision is a fitting
tribute to that legacy Adriana you
represent a community of scholars a
community of students who themselves
each and every one are extraordinary and
even among this extraordinary group you
stand out congratulations
thank you I am very honored to receive
this award and I would like to take
thank the MLK committee and the omie
staff for all of their hard work and
efforts in making this event a success I
never thought that my name would be
associated with such an excellent
individual as dr. Martin Luther King jr.
when I think of dr. King and the
motivation he possessed it makes me ask
myself what else can I do to become a
better leader whether I become a
professor in the future or whether I
decide to work in industry I always want
to keep dr. Martin Luther King Junior's
characteristics in mind during the years
when dr. King was at the top of the
civil rights movement leading hundreds
of people he never became power-hungry I
deeply admire him for that and I pray
that in times of success and achievement
humility will not be forgotten what I
admired the most about dr. King is that
God always came first in his life when
there were struggles he would pray to
God to give him strength and patience
and I'm sure that when things were going
well his first instinct was to thank God
for his blessings
these are things that I always want to
keep close to my heart I accept this
award with gratitude I also accept it as
a challenge to continue in my path to
educate myself as well as others and at
the same time never forget the important
things in life humility and faith in God
thank you
[Applause]
before I turn things back to Shana I
just wanted to add one more comment and
observation I too would like to thank
mr. M Fumi for his truly inspiring
remarks which were delivered with with
passion with grace in a way that I think
everybody in this room was moved we have
a problem at MIT and that is getting
students to come to classes at 9 o'clock
in the morning and I think we've
discovered a solution and so I would
like to extend an invitation to mr. M
fumet that if he can hold a crowd like
this at this hour we'd love to have you
teach physics so thank you very much
thank you very much and congratulations
to all the recipients now is my pleasure
to introduce Provost Robert a brown who
were recognized in 1998-1999
Martin Luther King jr. visiting
professors Provost Brown Thank You Shana
this morning has reminded me of an
extraordinary number of things but I
think it's reminded us all of the
commitment we have to have a building an
academic community that exemplifies the
path that Martin Luther King jr.
challenged us to follow the Martin
Luther King jr. visiting professor
program began in 1994 to bring the MIT
outstanding scholars to participate in
teaching and research at the Institute
and to enrich our community appointments
to this program are made upon
recommendations from the departments and
to the provost this year there have been
five Martin Luther King jr. visiting
professors I'd like to take this
opportunity to recognize the four
individuals who are here this morning
and to introduce you at least through my
words to the fifth I'll ask each one to
stand before at the table where I was
sitting seated and give you a brief
description of them
dr. Lloyd Demetrius
dr. Demetrius is visiting in the
department of brain and cognitive
science he is with the Department of
Biology at Harvard University and is an
expert in mathematics and biophysics in
in the wonderful world of nonlinear
dynamical systems his research at MIT
has spanned across biology chemistry in
brain and cognitive science and is now
taking him into bioengineering and
chemical engineering this spring his
teaching has been in the course
evolutionary psychology in BCS co-taught
with Professor Steven Pinker truly
integrated in the community
let me introduce mr. sterling hunter
mr. hunter is a visiting professor of
management in the Sloan School where his
research is focusing on organizational
design in art the organized
organizational consequences of
information theory and in my team mr.
hunter is also interested in the virtual
organization his teaching has been in
the graduate subject in strategic
management
let me introduce dr. Linda Jordan dr.
Jordan is visiting the Department of
Chemistry she's currently an associate
professor in the Department of Chemistry
at North Carolina Agricultural and
technical State University her research
is in the area of human biochemistry and
expertise in enzymes especially an
enzyme that affects diseases in man
including arthritis asthma pulmonary
disorders and cancer and MIT she's
focused on research along with
undergraduate students on cloning a
specific enzyme in examining the
structural properties of its structural
properties let me introduce dr. Pamela
McCauley Bell
pamela is visiting in the Department of
aeronautics and Astronautics she's
currently an associate professor in
industrial engineering and management
systems in the University of Central
Florida her research isn't focuses on
the development of intelligent software
and predictive models to address
information warfare information security
and human factors problems she's worked
here in the field of human impact of
information security where she's brought
her expertise to a range of groups in
the aero-astro department including the
human factors groups and the group
focused on intelligent systems she's
been teaching a seminar in information
security and she served as the adviser
to seven freshman and two graduate
students while here not with us today is
dr. Arnold Stansell who visited this
fall in the Department of Chemical
Engineering he's a professor currently
at the University of Georgia Institute
of Technology and has returned this
spring to teach there while at MIT he
brought to bear his enormous experience
Arne spent 31 years at mobile before
coming back into the academic profession
he's while here he consulted on energy
issues in the energy lab helped
supervise graduate students and taught
in a core thermodynamics course in
chemical engineering each of these
individuals has enriched the environment
of MIT enormous Lee over their time here
and we look forward to in many cases the
time they have left with us thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Provost Brown for recognizing
our faculty we will now continue with
some announcements that are relevant to
this morning's celebration first there
will be an installation of the Martin
Luther King jr. design project in Lobby
7 at 11 a.m.
Samiha McCord will be performing at noon
in Lobby 7 also there will be a
conference called sisters in cyberspace
youth conference held here at the
Institute on February 6 finally they
will excuse me there fourthly there will
be a presentation than the Black Student
Union which is right through those doors
hosted by the installation committee
from 4:00 to 5:00 p.m. today
finally the South Mass Choir will be
performing in Lobby 7 also at 5:00 p.m.
so I hope you all can attend those
events now would like to introduce
Champlain Betsy Draper who will offer
the benediction for the close of this
morning's program Champlain Draper
everyone stand together please
here we pray O God and father of
humankind forgive our foolish ways may
our renewal today starve the Beast of
racism a favoritism never to devour the
dream of justice for all may our actions
our conduct our words our deeds nourish
the dream and to the reality of harmony
today we ask for courage to serve and to
continue to serve to never give up as
components of change for good in an
ever-changing world we ask for direction
we ask for your sustaining presence as
we rally round the standard of blind
equality leaving behind in the pit our
desires for blind power and pride Oh God
and father of humankind we look forward
to a better day we ask these things amen
well originally we had scheduled for the
MIT gospel choir to sing but now we are
going to move on to just a closing
I hope you may all be seated I mean all
they say that
I hope you all have enjoyed this
morning's program as much as I have and
have taken a moment to reflect and
remember dr. King and the life and the
legacy that he is left behind thank you
all for coming and of course we hope to
see you next year and this concludes the
25th annual Martin Luther King jr.
celebration thank you
[Applause]